[Musique]
chaque enfant est une promesse c'est la
conviction d'espérance banlieu depuis 10
ans le réseau qui compte 17 écoles en
France lutte contre les inégalités
scolaires et culturel implanté dans des
quartiers sensibles les écoles proposent
des méthodes d'apprentissage différentes
personnalisées et au sein d'effectifs
réduit aujourd'hui je visite l'une
d'entre
[Musique]
elles aujourd'hui on est au cours la
boussole c'est une école qui accueille
des élèves de la Petite Section ocm2
cette école elle appartient au réseau
espérance banlieu elle est assez
particulière et justement pour en savoir
plus on va aller retrouver le proviseur
de l'école qui est en train d'accueillir
les
élèves tous les matins le le directeur
et ou monsieur bureau responsable de la
vie scolaire
on accueille les on accueille les
familles et notamment les élèves et on
se on se sert la main en se regardant
bien dans les yeux en se demandant si on
a passé un bon weekend et si on est prêt
à passer une une chouette journée
ensemble c'est une bonne manière de bien
commencer la journée exactement et alors
ensuite les enfants vont se ranger en
par équipage dans le dans la cour et et
on va faire ce qu'on appelle le
rassemblement le rassemblement qui a
lieu tous les matins les élèves
méritants sont appelés par leur par
leurs professeurs les élèves méritants
c'est sont les élèves qui se sont fait
remarquer euh la journée précédente ou
les journées précédentes euh que ce soit
aussi bien en classe par leur leurs
résultats Scola ou leur attitude leur
comportement envers un adulte envers un
autre camarade et donc ils sont appelés
pour être récompenser pour être félicité
par par leur professeurs cet appel en
fait c'est il monte les couleurs il lèv
les drapeaux et et on chante la
Marseillaise les tendard sont
élevés en rendez-vous dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
au
citoyens bon bah c'est parti on va en
cours on arrive dans une salle de classe
de
CB
bonjour tous les matins les élèves
commencent par le réveil du corps avec
des exercices comme la gymnastique des
doigts on fait la gyme des doigts ce
matin les pouces contre les pouces vont
faire bravo juste les pouces bravo bravo
bravo après le réveil place aux matières
fondamentales comme les mathématiques ou
le français pour faciliter la
compréhension des maths Marie leur
enseigne la méthode de Singapour basée
sur une progression continue du concret
à l'abstrait les enfants ont besoin euh
qu'on parte du concret donc nous
utilisons beaucoup de matériel euh et
lorsque les enfants ont compris avec le
matériel nous utilisons euh enfin euh
les chiffres uniquement les les
opérations mais tout est basé vraiment
sur du matériel donc je peux vous
montrer j'ai une une une armoire de de
matériel euh euh donc nous utilisons euh
et alors nous utilisons des bouliers
bien sûr
ça c'est
indispensable nous utilisons des trains
de cube donc qui sont aussi à la base de
la méthode
Singapour nous avons
également des tablettes en bois pour
comprendre en fait la
composition des chiffres donc dans 35 il
y a 30 et 5 et alors par exemple avec ça
comment est-ce que vous expliquez
avecfin quel type d'exercice on peut
faire alors là déjà c'est ce boulier le
boulier il est très utile pour
comprendre euh le système décimal
puisque en fait sur chaque ligne il y a
10 10 petites perles en fait donc déjà
ça c'est très important ça permet aussi
de diviser la dizaine en deux paquets de
cinq ouais ce qui permet de simplifier
donc là l'enfant va pouvoir être dans
l'analyse et donc le 10 est simplifié en
5 + 5 ok voilà et donc après avec ça on
CP on fait plutôt des des opérations
très simples comme par exemple tout
simplement les additions les
soustractions et en fin de CP on peut
voir le début de la multiplication
l'école présente plusieurs
particularités dont la pratique du
vouvoiement des professeurs vis-à-vis de
leurs élèves le port de l'uniforme est
également obligatoire bien qu'en cette
première semaine de rentrée tous les
élèves ne l'ai pas encore reçu et enfin
l'application des parents à l'école
c'est Guillaume bureau le responsable
éducatif qui nous en parle les méthodes
qu'on met en place à l'école et bien les
parents on les invite à les à les
connaître on va leur apprendre des
choses toutes bêtes pour que à la maison
en fait il y a une continuité et pareil
niveau de discipline par exemple un
enfant qui fait qui se bat qui fait une
bêtise n'importe quoi et bien on en
parle aux parents pour décider soit
d'une sanction ensemble soit d'un
comportement commun à avoir parce que il
y a rien de pire qu'un enfant qui voit
l'école dire quelque chose et la famille
contredire ce que fait l'école et vous
avez déjà un exemple d'un enfant qui qui
s'est épanoui au fur et à mesure ici on
a on a plusieurs exemples et tout
bêtement vous avez derrière vous un
tableau avec des points d'équipage donc
c'est-à-dire qu'on valorise les enfants
pour les bonnes actions et on a des
parents qui ont mis en place un peu ce
même système là pour des enfants qui
viennent ici soit pour des problèmes de
comportement soit qui à un moment il y a
une lassitude scolaire ou peu importe
les raisons euh et bien dans ce cas-là
c'est c'est très motivant parce qu'il
retrouve finalement le même système à
l'école et à la maison
etohérence le même système que par
exemple une mauvaise action ne va pas
impacter un groupe donc on va pas
retirer de point à l'équipe ou un enfant
fait une bêtise parce que l'idée c'est
de valoriser et c'est pas justement de
de de dégrader une situation on peut
aller la voir cette carte bien sûr elle
est hop est juste là donc vous avez euh
vous avez ici des les blasons des
différents équipages et donc vous voyez
là certaines équipes ont déjà remporté
des points plus ou moins et parce que il
y a des bonnes actions qui ont été
recensé comme ce matin il y a eu pendant
le rassemblement il y a eu deux points
qui ont été attribués justement parce
que l'idée c'est de valoriser au maximum
et qu'à la fin de l'année l'idée c'est
de remporter la coupe des équipages un
peu comme dans Harry Potter avec la
coupe des quatre
[Musique]
maisons et voilà c'est la fin de la
matinée c'est également la fin de cet
épisode donc vous l'avez vu on était au
cours la boussole à ment la jolie donc
cette école qui lutte contre les
inégalités scolaires et culturelles
j'espère que vous en avez appris
énormément de choses et on se retrouve
pour un prochain
[Musique]
numéro euh qu'est-ce que j'aime le plus
dans cette école c'est les
professeurs qui enseigne bien et et la
vie scolaire et tout le monde
je travaille plus et j'arrive plus à me
à me
dépasser moi quelque chose qui me tient
à cœur à l'école c'est mes amis et c'est
la façon de travailler
[Musique]
aussi